my my dad um he's he's like he reads his
Bible and he's he prays but he doesn't
have like a he doesn't go to church or
anything like that he
just um well when I like tried like when
I in the past when I was actually when I
was still a Baptist um I tried to get
him to church and he said like well I
need to find a church that like I want
to be around the people there
or well that's not the standard of going
to a church is I want to be around the
people what it's he's going to be the of
which group he's going to affiliate with
that's that's I mean if that's the case
then say Dad what if someone says I'm
not going to go to church because you're
there because they can't stand
you the standard isn't well I'm going to
find people that I want to associate
with no no I want to be in the Church of
Jesus Christ that Jesus wants me to be
in aective of the people because if you
wait
for running into the right people to go
to church Church you're never going to
go to church in fact read your Bible
read the New Testament the very
Christians that the apostles converted
were some of the most wicked selfish
carnal narcissistic individuals you
could meet they gave every excuse not to
go to
church right yeah but did that stop the
apostles from building churches or
ministering to churches or affiliating
with Christians
absolutely not that's not the standard
man right yeah so like on top of that he
um one of the biggest things that led me
to like the Orthodox Churches is me like
I was raised like my dad doesn't even
know what like doesn't even know what
solos scriptor means yeah just Bible
believes it's God's word right yeah
exact like he has that belief so hard
that he like genuinely believes it's
literally he can say in his room and
read the Bible that's where you catch
him hey Dad you believe every word of
that Bible right what is he going to
tell you he's going to say absolutely
and he say you believe that if you love
the Lord Jesus Christ you will do your
best to honor him and Obey him right
even though you do it imperfectly
right absolutely what what what will he
say to you he he would say yes so then
why do you disobey Christ by not being
part of the church that's in the Bible
it is do not forsake the uh Gathering of
the Saints 2325 or Hebrews
13:17 where it says that you are to obey
your leaders in all things because they
will have to give an account to your
soul right so therefore don't make it
burdens burdensome on them because it
won't bold well for you on that day
right say who are these Spirit-filled
leaders that watch over your soul
that and then First Corinthians 12: 12
all the way to 27 it talks about we're
all members of the same body of Jesus
Christ baptized in one spirit in one
body right and we drink from one spirit
and we're all members of the body and
one part cannot say to the other there's
no need of you we all need each other
because we're part of the body and we
can't function apart from the body so so
where's the body of Christ dad where's
your
church right yeah he won't he won't have
an answer that's right so you show them
from scripture let scripture convict
them say you love the word of God you
believe the Bible's God's word do you
believe the god of the Bible is real the
Lord Jesus Christ is real he's Almighty
well here's what the Bible says about
the church
dad and then Matthew 16:18 the Lord
Jesus Christ
says I will be building my church and
the gates of Hades will not Prevail
against it where is that church that you
belong to
Dad
right and then read for me Romans 1616 I
Romans 166 Romans 1616
show from scripture that he needs to be
part of the congregation the body of
Christ The Church of Jesus Christ Our
Lord here Romans 16:16 greet one another
with a holy kiss the Churches of Christ
greet you who greets you the Churches of
Christ so where is this church there's
none okay so how is he loving the Bible
and honoring the Lord Jesus Christ by
disregarding these
commands he's not okay what about 1
Timothy 3:15
First Timothy
3:15 verse
3:15 but if I am delayed I write so that
you may know how you ought conduct
yourself in the house of God which is
the Church of the Living God the pillar
and the ground of Truth wait the
household of God is
what the pillar and the ground of Truth
the household of God is what which is
the church of the Living God ah so God
has a household we are that household if
we're born of the spirit we are the
Church of the Lord Jesus Christ and God
has rules how to conduct ourselves in
his
house so if he's reading the Bible then
here the Bible says he's part of a
church if he's baptized by the spirit
he's a member of the body of the Lord
Jesus Christ meaning there are other
members who are united to him and he has
to do life with that has leaders
watching
over the church so where is this church
in fact when people got baptized notice
what they did go to Acts 2 37-47 Acts 2
37- 47 and you're going to pay attention
to 42 on what would they do once they
heard the gospel got baptized then what
did they
do acts 237 to 47
Acts 2
37-47 now when they heard this they were
cut to the heart and said to Peter and
the rest of the Apostles men men and
Brethren what shall we do then Peter
said to them repent and let one let
every one of you be baptized in the name
of Jesus Christ for the remission of
sins and notice first thing is they have
to turn to the Lord Jesus Christ confess
him be baptized for his sake in
obedience to his
command and then what happens
and you shall receive the gift of the
holy spirit all right for the for the
promise is to you and to your children
and to all who are far a far off as many
as the Lord Our God will call and many
with other words he testified and
exhorted them saying be saved from this
perverse generation then those who
gladly received the word were baptized
and that day about 3,000 Souls were
added to them notice they were added to
the Believers
they were now included in the body of
Believers the Apostles of the Lord Jesus
Christ their disciples now they were
added to their communion
right yes now watch guys the importance
of the church listen may we practice
what we preach keep going and they
continued steadfastly in the apostles
Doctrine and fellowship in the so what
was their
responsibility they continued fastly in
the apostles Doctrine and fellowship oh
so when they believed in the Lord Jesus
Christ and got baptized they were added
to the body of Believers and they
continued daily to learn the
doctrine the apostles would then teach
them because Jus said teaching them to
obey everything I commanded you so they
would learn at the feet of the apostles
then
what in the breaking of bread and in
prayers oh so they would gather together
also break bread and pray together
yes keep going look what they did then
fear Came Upon every soul and Many
Wonders and sign were done through the
apostles now all who believed were
together and had all things in common
and sold their possessions and goods and
divided them among all as anyone had
need did you catch what they did because
they were a body of Believers if there
was someone in need they'd make sure
their need was met so if you're
financially struggling the others who
are allive would then provide for you
because that's why the church does we're
a body who loves the Lord Jesus Christ
and for his sake love one another by our
Deeds but what watch what else they
did so continuing daily with one Accord
in the temple daily they would meet
daily they would continue daily with one
Accord having the
same
mindset same purpose to gather together
be a family together worship Jesus
together grow together and preach
together keep
going and breaking bread from house to
house they ate their food with gladness
and simplicity of heart praising God and
having favor with all people and the
Lord added to the church daily those who
were being saved so here is what the
Bible that your father reads if he's
baptized then he's part of that
community of believers who are born of
The Same Spirit belong to the same Jesus
Christ Our Lord the Jesus Christ and
have qualified leaders then ministering
to your father what the scriptures mean
how to apply them breaking bread that's
the Eucharist right praying together
worshiping together but here let me give
you some more guys remember these
passages all right remember these
passages please remember them when we
practice what we preach we cannot do
Christianity and isolation that's not
what the Bible teaches now go to 1 John
chapter 1 1 John chapter 1 read three
all the way to
7 1 John chapter 1
3-7 first John chapter
1 verses
3-7 vers um that which we have seen and
heard we declare to you that you also
may have fellowship with us and truly
fellowship with the apostles with us the
church so wait wait I'm confused John
says we are testifying to what I and the
other Apostles saw with our eyes heard
with our ears and touched physically
with our hands we physically touch the
word of life life the eternal life who
with the father when he became flesh and
became a man we touched him we held him
we saw him and now we're proclaiming him
to you so that if you believe and the
Lord Jesus Christ to our witness then
you will join us and have fellowship
with us everyone see that right in Jesus
name may you pay attention because these
questions will help you learn are you
seeing that to be a believer means to be
United with other believers to form a
family because Bad Company corrupts good
morals but when you find like-minded
folk who love Jesus the way you love
Jesus and then you unite to them that
will only make you better and
stronger so he says your fellowship is
with us and not only with us
your fellowship is with
who and truly our fellowship is with the
father and with his son Jesus Christ
keep reading and these things we write
to you that your joy may be
full this is the message which we have
heard from him and declare to you that
God is light and in him is no Darkness
at all if we say that we have fellowship
with him and walk in darkness we lie and
do not practice the truth now what he
means is darkness represent reprs Satan
sin evil the world that is under the
influence of evil making evil good and
calling good evil if we walk in the
light meaning if we walk in Union with
the Father the Son the Lord Jesus Christ
by the holy spirit that indwells us and
God is pure light there's no evil in him
no darkness in him then we will refrain
from Evil from sin we will condemn what
the world loves and we'll affirm what
the world hates we will hate what God
hates love what God loves and will avoid
sin just like God Is sinless So if we
walk in the light as he's in the light
then what we have fellowship with one
another and the blood of Jesus Christ
his son cleanses us from all sin there
you see the connection if I'm born of
the spirit United to the Lord Jesus
Christ I will act like Jesus and then it
will result in me having fellowship with
others who are born of the spirit
so this is what you show your dad say
hey Dad you believe that Bible but
where's your church dad